just before we get started I do want to
say that this video is sponsored by
world of warships the thinking man's
action game register below over a bunch
of bonuses more on the minutes North
Korea wouldn't be that well-known if it
wasn't for its nuclear tests it's
tyrannical and extravagant governments
and its characteristic insults of
international leaders especially those
from the United States comparatively
speaking poor country a country that has
just over 25 million inhabitants no
relevant industry or commerce and a
strikingly low purchasing power however
North Korea has been is and will be a
leading player in many international
forums and summits due to its constant
human rights violations and its advanced
nuclear and ballistic program the fact
is that 2019 was a particularly
complicated year for its dictator Kim
jong-un and 2020 doesn't look much
better
[Music]
because you see along with the effects
of international sanctions on imported
materials and products of all kinds the
country is going through a severe food
crisis due to droughts floods and other
circumstances that have caused crop
yields to drop to a five-year low to
give you an idea food shortages are
estimated to affect almost 40% of North
Koreans this means that the state cannot
guarantee the minimum nutritional
requirements to more than ten million
people so ten million people now depends
on international humanitarian assistance
[Music]
South Korea for example has offered them
50,000 tons of rice to alleviate hunger
however as we've told you before on
visual politic despite this difficult
situation the North Korean economy has
been growing for years although growth
has come in a somewhat strange informal
chaotic way and is largely driven by the
black market the truth is that North
Korea's economy has made certain
progress in recent years
[Applause]
[Music]
we're talking about an irregular
economic growth but it's estimated that
in some years it averaged a five percent
annual rate but don't get too excited
we're talking about growth rates where
the starting point was extreme poverty
and growth witches only reached certain
urban centers
[Music]
forty percent of North Koreans living in
rural areas aren't even guaranteed
energy growth and the North Korean
government's investments in particular
can only be seen in very limited areas
such as Pyongyang and other secondary
cities like one sun-sin a Jew a race on
or Sami on in the rest of North Korea
people basically have to go out and
count the few remaining trees in the
erratically deforested landscape in
order to keep warm in the winter this
image this reality greatly clashes with
the others that is projected
this is the new Pyongyang that a North
Korean regime is trying to build and we
aren't just talking about Pyongyang in
recent years they've endorsed macro
projects that are no longer focused only
in the capital projects which have
prompted the international community to
ask are these the results of the
megalomania of Kim jong-un a young
dictator who grew up studying in private
schools in Switzerland and watching NBA
games or are they signs that the
government wants to change we can't
answer that question but in this video
we're gonna tell you about North Korea's
main macro projects and you might be in
for a surprise by the way if you want to
know where the North Korean government
gets the resources for all of these
projects do not miss the videos that I'm
linking to in the description below just
before we continue with today's video I
do want to tell you about world of
warships the best way for me to do that
is to jump over to the computer this
game is just as it loads I'll tell you
this is a massive game you commands a
huge naval fleet there are just an
absolutely endless number of ships that
you can command and it's incredibly
detailed you can see there's different
weather depending on the situation here
you can see it's pretty polar it's
pretty icy oh that guy's got dazzle
camouflage that's very cool she's made a
video about this Wow this this this
battle spotting up
well at least I got that guy where are
these guys coming from it's so foggy aim
where he's gonna be Simon come on fine
let's get him yep dude I can see the
ships on fire is really on fire this is
good news so I'm just gonna sit around
capturing this area guys I should tell
you what you can actually get a few sign
off there are link 252 balloons a
million credits they become a
millionaire in this game you get the USS
Charleston as a bonus ship just for
joining through our link so yeah guys
we're definitely gonna win this one this
is world of warships sign up below and
yes enjoy the game there we go beautiful
sweet victory
[Music]
young yang from Stalinist gray to
multicolored megalomania when we think
of Pyongyang many of you might think
only of the husk of that gigantic
pyramid shaped hotel that cost a bomb to
complete
[Music]
a husks that didn't see a single worker
for more than 15 years between 1992 and
2008 construction was completely
paralyzed simply because the North
Korean government lacked the resources
to complete it
first as a result of the fall of the
Soviet Union and then due to the effects
of the arduous March a famine that ended
the lives of more than 2 million people
it's a building that's been called one
of the great emblems of the regime whose
construction was implemented by Kim
il-sung the grandfather of the Kim
dynasty and remains unfinished
throughout Kim Jong Il's entire era and
which Kim jong-un covered with glass and
a giant LED screen what's inside well
nobody can tell as for a hotel the real
hotel doesn't look like one since its
completion in 2016 not a single guest
has been seen to enter in other words
we're looking at a first-class prop
[Music]
but don't think this is a useless micro
project not at all wait to see what has
been erected in Pyongyang in recent
years and what's to come
[Music]
for example there's the Mirai Street of
scientists Mirai means future in Korean
it's a Street full of residential
skyscrapers shops and restaurants
serving Korean and international food
this avenue was opened as a prize for
the nuclear program scientists and the
university professors who were in step
with the regime
it has car access control which makes it
kind of a gated neighborhood social
classes who said anything about that and
that's not all the most recent one in
ROM Young Avenue was inaugurated in
April 2017 and has almost 20 residential
skyscrapers many of them painted with
blue and turquoise and decorated with
lots of tiles to imitate the color of
the glass of modern skyscrapers in
neighboring South Korea and China
[Music]
so what exactly is the real objective of
these projects well here the goal is
twofold
a local objective and an international
one
[Music]
the local goal was the message that
Kendra known wanted to transmit to the
North Korean power core in his early
years as a leader Kim wanted to convey
the idea that even though he was young
he would be the one to modernize develop
and transform the country no matter what
happened outside it and in a way this
was good news for the international
community and a parent's change of
spirit although the truth is that
wasting resources on such sterile
projects doesn't look like the best way
to achieve it
and on the other hands Kim builds all of
these works which she can't afford to
convey a message to the outside world
something like yeah I mean you could
throw all the sanctions he wanted me to
chase socialism is strong and it will
resist because that's precisely the
message that holds Kim in power even if
he's only pretending in any case what
seems clear is that this kind of golden
veneer will continue for a while Fong
yang Kim jong-un just presented a new
macro project in 2019 to completely
change the neighborhood that surrounds
the ghost hotel KCTV reveals large-scale
plans for districts surrounding iconic
new byung hotel and K news but just a
second so far we've only talked about
the capital but what's happening outside
Pyongyang is Kim also promoting these
types of projects outside the flashy
capital the answer is well yes he is in
fact the most outlandish projects being
carried out beyond the capital in
particular in Samian in the column a
peninsula
in the city of once an
[Applause]
but of course you're probably thinking
Simon who's ever heard of those places
the pronounciation dictionary definitely
hasn't well until now they had no
relevance whatsoever but Kim is a good
kid who was educated in Switzerland
wants to have his own version of a
European star ski resort as well as his
own summer vacation town and that's
exactly what he's making the objective
supposedly to flood his country with
tourism in 2018 North Korea received a
record number of visitors 1.2 million
Chinese tourists 50 percent more than in
2017 and along with them the odd handful
of tourists from other nations of course
they're all duly accompanied by guides
who control their movements at all time
yes tourism fever seems to be reaching
even as far as North Korea we like to
know more about Kim's ultimate
commitment to gain the foreign currency
he died early needs after all of the
international sanctions well listen up
[Music]
two new cities for summer and winter to
turn North Korea into something like the
Thailand's of Northeast Asia Kim jong-un
is spending a lot of money a lot
considering the country's economic
standing to create tourist complexes we
can see two of the greatest examples in
Semyon and karma
semion is a town located at the foot of
mount pike to which according to Korean
tradition is the place where Korea was
founded and also where according to
North Korean propaganda cartoons Kim
Jong Il was born and you know where
birds sang and a bright rainbow danced
on the horizon
the fact is that today this region is
better known for being one of the most
beautiful natural places in the country
and for having fantastic conditions who
winter sports and that's precisely where
kyndra Ninh decided to build his
miniature Switzerland
therefore he ordered the entire town to
be demolished to build a new one with a
large hotel shops apartment blocks and
houses with colored roofs to house 4,000
families 380 public and industrial
buildings and of course a few ski slopes
all this was built in a year and a half
of course when we look behind the
curtains the story isn't as impressive
[Music]
complete the built the regime employed
semi slave labor and even the army
itself workers were mobilized from
forced labor camps and tricity and to be
redirected from the surrounding towns
leaving the towns without power and all
this in order to finish and planned in
the first quarter of 2020 to be able to
take advantage of that year's winter
season because if there's one thing Kim
needs its cash dollars euros yen
yuan money perhaps with a bit of luck
one or two Chinese tourists will go down
his ski slopes and stay in one of his
soulless accommodations anyway
Semyon has been sold by the regime as
the socialist utopia the demonstration
that the regime can create a wind
paradise however Martha for an executive
director of the prestigious Pritzker
architecture prize doesn't see it that
way check this out it's just a simple
ski resort it doesn't reflect any new
ways of living it's a little emphasis on
urban quality and public land use and it
doesn't project spaces where people can
develop a full life Martha thorne
executive director of the Pritzker Prize
but will be on these debates about urban
planning in the fact that it seems
economically unfeasible
Semyon is currently at one of the best
places in the worst place on the planet
the question now is whether they'll be
able to reproduce this in kalma in the
city of 1-san what is being built there
is almost the opposite of the snowy
Sammy Yan we're talking about a true
summer vacation city
[Music]
from end to end it consists of almost
five kilometres of buildings that are
all currently under construction all
this with a newly remodeled airport into
beautiful and shiny terminal sewerage
nobody flies kim jeong-hoon
wants it to be the Cancun of the East
Sea the North Korean Miami is the
Communist Benidorm
the project's magnitude makes it perhaps
the most expensively unrestrained
project of the last decade of the
impoverished North Korea we're talking
about 12 hotels to shopping centers 26
commercial buildings cinemas and
exhibition palace and arcade game
building and indoor waterpark an ice
skating rink a restaurant complex and
more than 48 mansions and 200 luxury
Chalet stoop nor in the tourist dollar
all this in a country that's close to
the world and anchored in extreme
poverty or a large part of the
population has trouble even getting the
minimum nutrients that they need to
survive
obviously most North Koreans are not
going to be able to enjoy this place the
country's elites senior officials and
perhaps some tourists may use these
services but the others well they
obviously won't and it doesn't stop
there because in addition to Pyongyang
Samian and once and other cities like
Sunnah drew on the border with China are
also seeing a certain real estate boom
[Music]
for example there's the construction of
the Sun shaped hotel in the kangmin
district it's designed to house
businessman wants the synergies special
economic zone between North Korea and
China is activated right now that zone
is crippled by international sanctions
[Music]
his idea is to reform the entire
riverfront of the Yalu River to not only
exploit the growing economic activity
that is brewing in this area thanks to
trade with China in the black market in
which the government itself participates
but also to make the view from the other
side where the prosperous Chinese city
of Dandong is located a picture of
development and prosperity now that
you're familiar with North Korea's main
macro projects there's something we
really need to clarify all these
projects may look like examples of
development but the reality is very
different in most cases these types of
projects simply end up empty because
there are no people to attend or
customers to pay for anything
they're just ghost towns if he doesn't
radically open up to the world Kim Jong
un will be wasting a hundreds of
millions of dollars which could be used
for many more necessary things such as
improving the country's poor
infrastructure give you an idea of the
more than 25,000 500 kilometers of roads
that the country has only 800 are paved
is barely 3 percent these resources
could also be spent on dams pipelines
and dikes to avoid flooding when it
rains heavily and also to collect water
reserves to prevent recurrent droughts
and therefore food shortages
[Music]
or it could be spent on boosting
electricity production once and for all
since most of the country is shrouded in
darkness at night but of course a ski
resort or a vacation town is much more
chic anyway what do you think do you
think that the country in general can
benefit from these tourism projects how
can we fill these hotels while North
Korea remains such a repressed place
where one can't even move without a
guide well leave your answer in the
comments below and I really hope you
enjoyed that video please do hit that
like button if you did also do check out
our friends at reconsider media they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine and as always thank you
for watching and if you want to learn
more about politics and hear even more
of my lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]
you